[Music]
so this is based on a popular list on
reddit they believe that these are the
movies that should never ever ever be
remade leave it exactly the way it is
we're going to go through it and see if
we agree or disagree let's do it number
one raiders of the lost ark
never seen it
moving on
leave it
if chris hasn't seen it
do you know who tom selleck is no okay
i'm sorry i don't watch a lot of things
honestly i don't know the original
magnum pi okay but their new magnum pi
has um a latin guy i think jay hernandez
was afraid last name anyway anyhow i
think she heard it
but tom selleck was offered the role of
raiders of the lost ark oh yeah he
turned it down
why turn it down so you're saying we
should have a modern one of with him as
exactly just really old that's an old
man there's an old man
though he's great i don't i can't
picture tom selleck no it's it's bizarre
it's gotta be someone else paris before
it's fired so they you guys who are fans
of raiders leave it alone leave it alone
i i didn't even watch it when it came
out like it was one of those movies that
i heard was a classic so i rewatched it
when i was an adult but me watching it
as an adult and then like kind of being
immersed in that world i was like dude
this thing's perfect i don't even want
to see it modernized or anything it's a
great adventure movie but you know if
they remake it i i hate one thing i hate
about remakes is
it's like oh we can't put the white
person in there again we gotta put it
right right right it's gotta be a
transgender asian man yeah yeah yeah
there's no transgender asian adventurers
though
you need to expand
that's because they don't have
representation you're wrong why are you
right you're right you're right that's
the problem man white people say right
all right here's one here's what i i
definitely 100 agree with shawshank
redemption oh yeah oh not touch that
movie i've never make it shorter
[Laughter]
let's get to the point
if you think about it if it was shorter
that that whole scene when he's like out
free won't be as impactful make that
longer
you made me wait two hours for him to do
this dude
you know if they did a party
see what life is outside is that like
titanic too yeah yeah yeah in mexico
mexico
yeah kind of like star wars you know
it's like how did he get there oh yeah a
prequel and then you find out he
actually did murder his wife you're like
damn this guy's a dick
this guy's a piece of [ __ ]
all right gladiator oh gladiator was
sick i think i think you could remake
that one oh i think you could i think
you could make it good
nick cannon
is this still said in rome yeah it has
to be instead of fighting they just like
do raps and like wild now he goes up to
the lion's drums and he goes are you not
in her pain
he was in the remake of can't buy me
love
like why would you remake can't buy me
love number one but he was the remake of
that i've only seen the original so he
should just you know how um oh god i
really i feel bad that i forgot his name
chadwick bozeman you know for a while he
was only doing um biopics biopic movies
he played like real life characters yeah
for a while and then he got black
panther
maybe nick cannon could be
like the remake guy
like hey we instilled nick cannon's
tatted
like he's wearing a turban yeah with the
american accent
yeah no you're not y'all okay
you guys watch bridgerton on netflix
bridgeton so shauna rhymes created
grey's anatomy and she did bridgerton
well bridgerton is set in like the
victorian era but everyone's it's
multi-ethnic oh that broke that whole
thing out and not everyone has accents
in there there's asians in there i don't
know if i like that the queen is black
so is it a period piece yes it's a
victorian era victoria times so nick can
could full well be in rome as a tatted
black man from san diego drums
and gladiators why does he have to be
this drumline character oh yeah that'd
be awesome that's his best character
yeah is it not his best
it
drumline is is a great film who who
directed gladiator i forgot it's it's uh
the really scott oh
dude imagine remember that opening scene
when he goes uh uh
he was when he when he does this
i'm not late never late yeah no when uh
russell crowe goes you know unleash hell
dude nick cannon with this dress
dude
i'm in bro dude i'm telling you guys man
i do think they can remake it because it
doesn't have like this i think it's a
really good movie yeah um
but i don't think that ingredients are
like irreplaceable yeah yeah yeah you
know what i mean that's what i think you
can see gal gadot
cause she looked kind of like a
gladiator in wonder woman you know yeah
put her as the main character and it
will be also helping the world crowd
because they want to see empowering like
women's health
a lion come out and just rip her armor
off yeah all their titties pop out
yeah
but she's still getting down like yeah
because it's not even about that it's
not about that it's not about that no so
the perverts are like oh well forever
titties
it's it's like she don't even need armor
yeah yeah that's all that's the deep
mess that's the deep neck she don't even
need armor
okay i didn't even need to recast her
sidekick digimon hanzo could just still
play the same dude and he played in the
original gladiator that's true here
here's one that i call it vibrator
instead of wow
sorry
come on let's spit balling there's a
writer
this is what the studios do man yeah
that just sounds like a parody porno
yeah you put on the board how about this
this one i know is not gonna get remade
anyway because the people who created it
vowed to never allow that back to the
future
oh thank god you can't no but if they
did nick cannon
as not martin
no no no not martin mcfly he's
oh doc he goes it only goes 88 beats per
minute
dude but nick and eddie murphy and nunny
professor he could play dog oh yeah and
marty dude
next
yeah sorry i picked the easiest one sure
steven spielberg uh robert zemeckis
steve spielberg yeah was i think
uppercase uh producer yeah
i don't know if any of his movies you
can remake in my opinion
schindler's list didn't they do jurassic
park we could redo that is that is that
not spielberg jurassic park was that
james cameron
no i think it was
no i don't know it may have been his
company
because like his movies have a certain
feel that i don't unless he's attached
to it i don't know if they can remake
and get the same feeling anything with
graphics and cgi can definitely be
remade because it's like it's back in
the 90s you're doing that remaster that
[ __ ] we're just replacing the actors
that's what we're really talking about
with nick
[Applause]
don't do that for this one oh yeah
godfather
i could see nick
he could be fredo yeah yeah italian girl
cannon could be like hey man you owe me
one you owe me one hey make him an offer
he can't refuse
that's kind of hard
that was great right there man you have
to work for him bro all right well you
did which character is he the marlin
brando one he's all of them again
i think he can give me michael though
he's a professor style what can he do
man yeah man dude yeah mariah carey you
know here's one that they're really
passionate about not touching terminator
one and two
nick kennedy
his name is nick cannon he will have
i see it he could just be nick cannon
the cannon is nick cannon i could kill
you i could hear him say hasta la vista
i see him
[Laughter]
oh i'll be back
but you know what i love those when they
when they remake these white movies they
cast minorities why don't we remake a
minority movie and cast white people
yeah we're like fruitvale station yeah
so we white face ourselves yeah like
dude i entered the dragon yeah like with
the white dude or like remember owen
wilson yeah
four don't hit back
like what's a classic black movie
uh boys another boys in the hood with
white people all white castle
same script same everything yeah dude
laurence fishburn could be played by ron
perlman oh
that actually would be good that
actually works
so
if you took it seriously that would be
good he's explaining gentrification
wait no you gotta do the opposite man
there's too many black people moving in
here we gotta move consider ricky's like
billy
skyler no
it's a slingshot
who replaces ice cube at boys of the
hood oh [ __ ]
logical logic jeff hardy bro
logical logic
another rapper
and he uh oh oh oh oh
post below yeah post
okay he's below chill though i don't
think i'd believe it
[Laughter]
white man can't jump yeah yeah really
yeah yeah so so do so we'll do white van
can't jump but then the white guy
actually can jump and the black guy
can't die exactly so it's called black
guy can't dunk yeah oh black guy can't
die that's actually a real movie
legit movie there's that classic scene
and not a lot of people remember but it
was in the movie that barry gory is the
last dragon
where a leroy is a black guy but he he's
asian
asian and then there's chinese guys they
were the best boys but they they talked
black yeah there's a great scene where
they're playing dice yeah that's that's
what little joe yeah
like it would be like uh white men uh
ken jones can jump black guy can't dunk
yeah yeah that's fire how do you feel
about this one my cousin vinnie
you got to leave that bro that when
you're leaving you got to leave it nick
cannon and godfather you're leaving this
alone bro you can't because like [ __ ]
what's the name uh marissa tomei too
[ __ ] good was it joe pesci
bro who's gonna replace joe pesci
nick cannon
danny devito he could be one of them
daddy devito plays joe pesci oh that'd
be fire
the rock
oh
the rock is as the judge
i know as a judge what do you what do
you mean
yeah
you're gonna get the philly straight up
you throw the rock in there how about
casino
who's gonna play robert de niro's
character the rock
diesel all right here's here's the last
one
home alone
oh no they already tried they tried to
do four this is working we make the
actual like original and like but if you
replace it that's just our childhood
dude home alone like [ __ ] if you're a
minority you're just watching tv eating
sandwiches actually one of the main
motivating factors behind doing remakes
is you're you're giving it to a new
audience yeah
do you think home alone even needs that
because you could still be a kid today
and watch that movie all those movies
are timeless except i'm surprised
germline's on that list yeah
that's my question with the remakes
though did all the dvds get lost
exactly you don't have access to them
anymore like i don't understand like why
they just can't hit play i feel like
they play these movies on tv pretty
frequently you know yeah i don't know if
kids are watching tv these days but
these are this is seasonal it's
christmas so they're gonna every
christmas they're getting right
yeah yeah like that home alone christmas
story yeah white christmas grinch yeah
they always play them every you know
it's like hey why don't they make remake
rudolph
you know
nobody want to see that [ __ ] anymore i
want to see nick cannon as rudolph yeah
and then
with his hooves playing a drone
do you think anybody else could play the
grinch other than jim carrey oh oh
oh yeah
johnny depp
oh
yeah that's right
he's just drunk all the time
right now
after this nick cannon brainstorm i
didn't realize how wide his range was
you're really good as an actor man
no it's not nick cannon's range it's his
drumline characters
that guy could go anywhere and how
confident he was in that he couldn't
read music bro
he couldn't read music and he's still
[ __ ] through
he put when he finessed to go to the
front he could have he couldn't play and
walk
him bro so the way he did it was like
could you imagine him in the godfather
hey don don what do we do i don't know
man i don't know but
i got this way to the front
think about this all done well done
[Music]